you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
the cost of conservation gabon's
environment minister calls for more
money to help protect forests essential
for absorbing carbon emissions
the number of environmental defenders
killed trying to protect ecosystems
reaches a record high
and our small solutions the more
reusable packaging enough to make a big
difference to the climate crisis that's
one of the topics up for discussion in
today's climate show debate
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the uk's only
daily climate news show where we track
the changes happening to our world right
now and challenge those who are coming
up with the solutions
first to gabon known as africa's green
superpower it's one of the most forested
countries on earth but its environment
minister has told sky news it'll be very
very difficult to continue to protect
the country's rainforest if it's not
properly rewarded for careful
conservation efforts
now nearly 90 percent of gabon is
covered by forests which captures more
carbon than the country emits some
forests there store more co2 than
similar forests in the amazon
on average each person in gabon
contributes about 2.2 tons of co2
emissions each year while in the uk the
average is more than double that at five
and a half tons
well since 1990 gabon's emissions have
stayed roughly steady about 4.7 million
tons in 2019 but if we look at the uk's
emissions they were far far bigger at
370 million tons but when you factor in
the carbon dioxide absorbed by gabon's
forests nearly a hundred million tons
every year the country actually becomes
a net carbon sink with negative
emissions and because of the reduction
in its co2 emissions gabon became the
first african country to receive a
payment of 12 million pounds from the
central african forest initiative
gabon is the fifth largest oil producer
in africa but as this source becomes
more scarce timber has become a valuable
asset to the country and the government
has agreed to keep deforestation at low
rates but says this comes at a cost
our climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter reports now on the choice facing
the country between profitable
commercial deforestation and preserving
the country's trees
we're in gabon on the west coast of
central africa at the invitation of its
government
they are flying us deep into the jungle
the aim to help us understand more about
one of the most forested nations on the
planet
from above the canopy you get a real
sense of the sheer scale of this forest
stretching for hundreds of miles in
every direction and covering nearly 90
percent of gabon
it's part of the congo based rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
gabon has been able to afford to leave
this jungle alone because it's an
oil-rich nation
but prices are plummeting production
dwindling and so that's about to
change you have to read the trees this
is the akumi tree
lee white is the country's british-born
environment minister
sixty percent of our economy is going to
disappear in the next 20 years
as as oil revenues disappear we have to
replace
those revenues with something else
that's something else is the forest
gabon wants the international community
to pay it for careful conservation or
risk deforestation for logging and
agriculture
i think it would be very difficult
to maintain
for us
long term
without a real partnership
between
developed and developing countries
and without
a business model an economic model that
makes rainforest valuable for the people
that that live in them
firstly we are looking for
forest elephants here we have two
species of elephants we have a savannah
and the forest elephant
degrading the forest would put one of
the most bio-diverse regions on the
planet at risk
in lope national park we see just some
of the wildlife that lives here
a family of chimps crossing the savannah
and later forest elephants
more than fifty thousand of them live in
gabon sixty percent of the world's
population
but even here climate change is having
an impact warmer temperatures reducing
fruit growth on trees pushing the
elephants into villages
that is
uh the big problem in gabon
every day there are intellections to eat
the plants like cassava everything which
the the woman plant
that night evidence on our doorstep of
the problem a group of 12 foraging near
our lodge
as climate change intensifies so does
the fragility and importance of this
ecosystem
gabon is one of the few countries on
earth that absorbs more carbon than it
emits
it's why this whole region is crucial to
the battle against climate change and
why what happens here will matter far
beyond national borders
this is the strength of gabon's
negotiating position at the cop 26 u.n
climate summit later this year
tonghi gahuma bakali is the man making
the argument for a new carbon market
that rewards conservation
because of the need to become emerging
countries all tropical countries in the
world lose their forest
it's a fact our forest is still uh
stunned the tree are still the sun so
now
help us
to
to to not become like other tropical
countries
gabon is at a crossroads
trying to make an environmental asset
profitable without destroying it a model
for the future but only if the rest of
the world agrees
hannah thomas peter sky news in gabon
well you can read more about hannah's
reporting from gabon on our website you
just head to sky news dot com forward
slash climate
now in today's other climate news at
least 30 people have been arrested after
climate protesters blocked several
junctions on the m25 motorists faced
long delays while the activists sat on
the roads during rush hour obstructing
turn-offs including heathrow airport and
swanley in kent campaigners from
environmental group insulate britain say
that they want government action on home
insulation
and the royal horticultural society has
launched a new campaign to encourage
gardeners to become more environmentally
friendly a recent survey from ugov found
that less than a fifth of gardeners are
using more sustainable methods in their
gardens the charity has come up with a
list of 10 climate-friendly actions that
people can take including using
rainwater to water their plants and
making their own compost
tesco is introducing a reusable
packaging system across 10 of its stores
in england in a bid to tackle plastic
waste customers will be able to buy
everyday products in packaging that can
be returned to the store to be cleaned
refilled and reused and we'll be
discussing if small solutions can make a
big difference or if they don't go far
enough that's in our daily climate show
debate and today i'm joined by the
science broadcaster and wwf trustee ziya
tong and the director of union of
justice magid magic that's coming up for
you in just a few moments time
now nicola sturgeon says that the
scottish government will fund cop 26
youth conference which will take place
ahead of the main un summit in glasgow
in november usually the government
hosting the meeting this year the uk
would also fund the conference of youth
well speaking to her party's conference
the first minister described the
wildfires extreme heat and storms that
have ranged around the world this year
as a wake-up
in a few weeks time world leaders will
gather here in glasgow for the un
climate change conference cop 26.
make no mistake this summit represents
the world's best chance probably our
last chance to limit global warming to
1.5 degrees in line with the paris
agreement
nobody underestimates the scale of that
challenge
but no one should underestimate the
impact on lives particularly the lives
of the world's poorest if we fail to
meet that challenge
now a record number of activists working
to protect the environment and land
rights were murdered last year the
campaign group global witness found that
227 people were killed in 2020 alone
while trying to protect forests rivers
and other ecosystems that their
livelihoods depend on here's more about
the environmental defenders on the front
line of climate change environmental
defenders are
any individuals who
engage in peaceful activism in order to
ensure that our rights to
the environment such as our right to air
right the water right land
is fully realized by any individual
[Music]
we think the
2020 was the deadliest year on record
because the stakes are really that high
in so far as environmental conflicts
around the world are concerned for
instance in the philippines we
experienced a doubling of killings of
environmental defenders are under the
current deter the government and this
coincides with a marked increase of
commercially operating large-scale mines
this coincides with steadily decreasing
forest power so the philippines ranked
in this latest iteration of the report
as the third deadliest country in the
world
uh the first would be colombia and that
would be followed by mexico i think that
the
crucial turning point would be to
to really have a strong policy basis for
asserting our rights uh
and so a legislation to to really
support environmental defenders would be
the crucial uh pivot to towards the the
increased safety and towards the
increased effectivity of the work of
environmental defenders
well do stay with us because coming up
after the break i'll be joined by the
science broadcaster and wwf trustee
zayatong and author and activist magid
magic good to see you both they're going
to be discussing if developing countries
should be paid to protect the
environment and whether small changes
can actually make a big difference
[Music]
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
as it is almost impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to philip
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations to philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm tom chescher and i'm skye's asia
correspondent based here in beijing
[Music]
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
start with a steel structure that we put
into the sea floor we then pass a very
small electrical current between what we
call an anode and the cathode and the
structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
it will be a rather cloudy start to
tuesday with outbreaks of rain in the
south heavy and possibly thundery rain
over southern england the midlands and
parts of wales will slowly move
northwards and it will feel muggy
scotland and northern ireland and the
republic will brighten up with just a
few showers
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high
low levels of air pollution are expected
to continue on tuesday and for much of
the week ahead
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news we're getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day and challenging the
solutions to them that is with the
science broadcaster and wwf trustee ziya
tong and director of union of justice
former mep and mayor of sheffield majid
majidev very good to see you both
tonight i want to start after uh the
gabon report that we were playing there
i just want to gauge your view on the
philosophy really is it the
responsibility of richer nations to be
helping developing nations with their
climate change goals magic what do you
think
100 yes and i'll explain
it it's firstly important to recognize
that the climate crisis is hugely unjust
like throughout the 19th and 20th
centuries countries like the uk and
those in the global north were and still
are some of the biggest the world's
biggest emitters of carbon pollution as
a direct result have become some of the
world's wealthiest nations let's be
frank that's it's largely happened at
the expense of developing countries such
as gabon in the global south and as a
result of issues like colonial and
post-colonial relations so countries
like you can other kind of more advanced
countries and in europe i've got a moral
obligation to compensate those countries
and communities that are negatively
impacted by climate change due to our
let's our collective failure to tackle
reasonable steps to limit our emissions
in the past as well and as today because
it's going to take a global approach to
it rather than just individual
approaches so a big yes from you imagine
what about you zaya
well i have to agree with madget there i
know that rich countries are
disproportionately responsible for
climate emissions and that poor
countries are disproportionately
impacted by climate change and so
obviously there's a debt to be paid from
rich countries to poor countries but
there's a way of going about that
there's good models and bad models uh
morocco and what's happening with the
green climate fund is an example of a
good model perhaps we can talk about
that but one thing that i want to point
out if you consider something like
losing weight as an analogy for lowering
emissions right now what the rich
countries are saying is hey we want to
eat all the ice cream and we want the
poor countries to do all the diet and
exercise it's all going to balance out
on the books but the question is you
have to say hey is this fair b even if
those poorer countries get fit they
can't continue on that treadmill if the
emissions continue to rise fundamentally
what needs to happen is that the rich
countries have to lower their emissions
and their resource use if you want to
see that real change they have to stop
eating that proverbial ice cream yeah i
mean you mentioned that and i just i
just want to bring in this quote here
because this really speaks to the issue
doesn't it uh here we go and really when
you've got the the richer nations um
enjoying the economic growth um that has
come as a consequence of damaging the
planet and then they're expecting
developing countries
to do their bit i mean we're
talking about a lift there for african
nations what does that lift look like
majid what do you think
well we need to unlock funds and
resources to developing countries that
are affected by
um years and legacies of extraction and
exploitation and i think a really good
first step and an essential one towards
repairing and this as well as historic
injustices and saving our planet is for
countries in the global north who are
and i'll keep repeating it responsible
for this crisis is to immediately engage
in a wide-ranging program of debt
cancellation towards developing
countries so what's to at least break
one link in that long history of
extractive exploitation the cop26 really
gives us a great opportunity to do that
yeah and zai what do you think imagine
proposing their debt cancellation does
that work
well i think that there's ways that you
can work with local countries so that
you're not imposing your ideas on
another sovereign nation uh and making
them develop like the old 1980s
development models what i like about
what morocco and the green uh the green
climate fund what they're doing right
now if i could share with you for an
instance in morocco they have argan
trees and these argan trees have been
harvested for millennia they produce the
nuts that make the oil for my hair but
it's also a great food source the forest
there are a buffer for desertification
for the sahara desert so right now those
forests are suffering from over
harvesting and climate change but what
the fund is doing is they are building
tens of thousands of hectares of argan
uh of orchards and so what that's going
to do is that's going to be an extra
buffer for desertification it protects
the natural forest and also it's going
to be a a sequestering device 500 000
tons of additional carbon being
sequestered by the trees but best of all
it helps the local economies and the
women in particular who have
cooperatives who've been doing this
traditional way of life with harvesting
the nuts and producing oil as an end
effect i get some argan oil for my
shampoo but fundamentally what we have
to do when we do this sort of transfer
of wealth is we have to consult with
local countries and we have to do things
that are to their benefit first
yeah it needs to be a consultation
doesn't it well let's move on now to
look at that new scheme that's being
launched to try and make it easier for
shoppers to recycle and reuse packaging
which we heard about earlier it's
designed to help encourage people to
purchase items in packaging that they
then return to the store so it can be
cleaned refilled and reused but are
small solutions enough to make a big
difference or do they in fact distract
from the large scale measures that are
needed and when you look here you can
really get a sense of the scale of the
problem there i mean i want to get both
of your views
on that and packaging is an immense
problem isn't it you can see that there
in the in the quantity of it and do you
think we think enough about it or does
it get lost in the debate about what we
eat majid
it does get lost at times and it's a
great start but and it's not enough
jealousy obviously reusable packages
changing your diet and other behaviors
like that is a step in the right
direction because i do believe that
when people actually kind of unites in
their activism which those small changes
are large large scale changes can
actually happen however that being said
like we must kind of really stay
vigilant and continue to put pressure on
companies and other elected and our
elected representatives to kind of
create that fair sustainable just world
that we desperately need to save the
planet because if we're only going to be
focused on
small and and individual acts we'll kind
of lose sight of the main culprits on
this it's not individual people like my
uncle abdul or stacy from greg's that's
responsible for two-thirds of all global
emissions it's 90 companies which our
government subsidizes so as well as
doing our small bit and repackaging
everything we kind of need to kind of
also make sure that we put in our
attention kind of holding those people
into accounts yeah well nobody's blaming
abdul and uh and stacy i should say
what do you think zion do you think um
this is just tinkering around the edges
it's only 10 stores it's only some
products does it miss the bigger issues
like haulage and food production
i think the thing is that what we're
seeing is that this debate is always
framed as an either or when it should be
both but it should be weighted so as an
example recently the extinction
rebellion scientists actually leaked a
draft report of the upcoming ipcc uh
report it's a draft of course but what
it suggested is that if 10 to 30 percent
of our citizenry actually did the good
work of reducing our emissions eating
less meat fewer air cons less flights
what we'd actually be able to do by 2030
is actually reduce emissions to the
equivalent of two brazils and change
those social norms so this is actually
quite fundamental to change but keep in
mind that's 10 to 30 percent the other
70 to 90 percent what needs to happen
there is enlightened policy making
regulation you need to have corporate
impact that is the heavy lifting that
has to be done the one thing i like
about the tesco loop project we have it
here in canada too we have it at loblaws
is it's actually just a twist on an old
idea it's the milkman model you're
paying for the milk you're not paying
for the bottle okay so if the company is
incentivized to keep making better
packaging that lasts a long time that we
can reuse again and again then that does
start to make a difference all right
really lively discussion with you both
ziya
thank you very much for your time on sky
news
well that's everything from us for today
joining me on the show tomorrow to
discuss all of the big climate issues
will be fatima ibrahim co-founder of
green new deal uk and bob ward from the
grantham research institute on climate
change and the environment but do stay
tuned for now coming up on sky news
tonight children aged 12 to 15 years old
to be offered a cover jab in the next
phase of the vaccine rollout thanks for
watching i hope to see you at the very
same time here tomorrow on sky news
[Music]
you